I'm happy that there's like a legit new
holiday classic these new families that
are existent you know that want to see
themselves being represented we feel one
of those things were the first one was
beloved and we figured it's not worth
going back unless we can make it better
and make it its own thing and now
introduce our dads and you know all the
complexities of having a new type of
structured family but us we're working
to do everything we can for the better
of the kids somebody had said oh they'll
never be a sequel and then the movie was
so beloved I talked to Sean he's like
thinking of this idea where the
Grandpa's family oh that is hilarious Oh
piercing eyes like a velociraptor really
is the funniest man it is true both of
those guys working with Will and Mark
who have this kind of crazy short and
that just it's worked so many times the
movie has this kind of wonderful sense
of improvisation about it the movie is
an awesome story that people just laughs
and enjoys tells it a good story it
focuses on the holidays the thing that
got me the most excited was bringing in
Mel Gibson and John Lithgow and what
they were gonna bring out of will and
Mark there you go bring the car around
on the curb this is Sarah's husband why
is he here to be able to play off all of
those dynamics about how all these guys
bounce off of each other
[Applause]
you share wonderful kisses with your
father junco in the film you've made out
with more people than any other actor so
which would either wall never shared an
onscreen
eye
you know I wanna do it on the big bad
thing
stop it no good cuz we're boys
[Music]
you